c'est ton anniversaire
non c'est
[Musique]
pas moi
des tripes
voilà regardez oh [__] en plus de ça
regardez ça comme ça
non mais je vois pas qui c'est qui
en scooter
vous assistez pas c'est tout ce que je
peux vous demander si c'était moi
j'arrive de bosser donc vous insistez
pas c'est pas moi
votre patron vous vous demandez votre
adresse
attention c'est chaud attention oh là là
oh non regardez ce que vous avez fait je
vais les revendre je vais les revendre
c'est pas grave
tu as goûtez-moi ça madame goûter moi ça
goûter moi ça goûter moi ça
Goûter Goûter Goûter
[Applaudissements]
alors comment elles sont non
vous si vous avez commandé des tripes je
mets dans la boîte aux lettres
tu t'envoises ça change tout de suite
dans la gueule toi quoi j'entends pas
je les mets dans la boîte aux lettres
[Applaudissements]
la télé c'est stère à la maison c'est
vous qui avez été tiré au sort
quelque chose
merci merci
[Musique]
on est bien
faudra le couper le téléphone ce soir
qu'on soit pas emmerdé
à Madame
vous allez faire les courses
la seule chose c'est qu'il faut que je
retourne à 6h chercher ma fille à
l'école
on regarde la maison
avec la petite là après
laissez-moi s'il vous plaît laissez-moi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
où il faut pas
il m'a dit le emplacement numéro 8
heures à la montée déjà
dormir encore une heure ou deux
on vous a dit
gens qui viennent jouer à côté de ma
tante
jusqu'à présent on parle très gentiment
on peut parler autrement si vous voulez
autrement comment ça
j'ai mal au crâne
c'était sympa mais oui
par terre
je vais prendre
j'arrive pas à dormir
non non non non
[Musique]
le code on va prendre monsieur machin
allez hop
oui bonjour dites donc c'est encore
votre chien qui a fait caca dans le dans
l'entrée là
tout le monde dit que c'est le vôtre
vous nettoyez où on le fait
[Musique]
bon bah ouvrez on va on va nettoyer mais
bon faites attention quand même
merci
et hop allô oui on est en train de faire
des essais est-ce que vous m'entendez
[Musique]
essayez voir d'appuyer sur le bouton
pour ouvrir la porte
[Musique]
merci
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
moi allez ouvre il fait froid
hein
allô oui bonjour madame c'est moule 30 à
l'appareil livraison de moules
marinières à domicile
[Musique]
pardon
en plus c'est super lourd pensez-vous il
y en a pour cette
m'envoie ça d'accord
oui bonjour c'est pour qui veut gagner
des millions
oh non merci monsieur
vous arrive
comment dit-on c'était trois frontons ou
c'était trois fonds 11
trois femmes
11 ans
c'était un piège
on peut pas faire gagner des millions
comme ça
bonjour bonjour elle est votre dame oui
parfaitement au profil type de
l'aménageur de moins de 45 ans on se met
dans la cuisine
[Musique]
et le texte c'est tartoche sur du pain
c'est fastoche stop
[Musique]
cette tête on dirait que vous mangez de
la crème
il faut commencer
madame
s'il vous plaît
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il y a du piment aussi
il y en a même plus d'autres choses on
dirait top
c'est pas bon c'est pas ça le texte
c'est peut-être le produit
c'est ton anniversaire
non c'est pas mon anniversaire
la petite course c'est pas mon
anniversaire quoi
bon je ferme parce que
qu'est-ce qu'il y a non non je ferme on
n'est pas au vin c'est le vin ici mais
oui c'est l'anniversaire de qui mais de
toi
non non non non non non
joyeux anniversaire
arrêtez tout de suite arrêtez tout de
suite
vous avez le droit de mettre des billets
si vous voulez
un petit coup pour la route
je vais pas voir le temps il faut que je
travaille madame
bonjour
c'est lequel Raymond
c'est ton anniversaire allez viens
allez viens quoi
parce qu'il faut que je vous donne le
slip comme cadeau à la fin
un petit bisou bonsoir c'est Pascal il
est 8h55 dans 5 minutes le match OM -
Paris Saint-Germain et comme j'ai pas de
télé comme d'habitude je suis allé chez
les gens on est à Marseille on est où là
à Marseille à Marseille je suis avec
cabel et puis on va taper chez les gens
on y va
c'est bon c'est bon c'est bon ça fait
rien comme ça il y a quelqu'un
bonsoir c'est Pascal selem pour MTV on
peut venir voir le match chez vous on
veut regarder le match
vous connaissez Kamel l'humoriste
marseillais on peut venir il y a pas de
souci
c'est gentil
je crois que tu es en train de tomber
amoureux de moi
oh non pas lécher pas lécher c'est à
vous le chien madame vous savez quoi on
va le tuer
moi je peux mettre les pieds là
je prends je suis désolé je veux pas
mettre le bordel
mais moi au moins j'enlève mes
chaussures
il y a que toi et moi je sais que les
odeurs pour les femmes enceintes c'est
très très fort il y a pas d'odeur vous
êtes sûr quand même
c'est quoi votre nom de famille
la fille et le beau-fils
un gros mot c'est une grande claque
[Applaudissements]
c'est quoi la spécialité culinaire de
Marseille
il faut combien de temps pour faire une
bonne bouillabaisse trois heures trois
heures moi je vous donne 10 minutes moi
vous avez de la boîte
vous avez mangé nous on a pas du tout
mangé
[Musique]
il y en a c'est possible
alors une un jus d'orange à la bière
parce qu'on a pas le droit à l'alcool et
moi un jus d'anis s'il vous plaît OK
et où est-ce qu'il casse son argent ton
papa
côté de l'ordinateur
dis-moi où dis-moi
en tout cas c'est la première fois qu'on
vient voir un match avec un couple
échangeiste
pendant toute la soirée le match c'est
important je sais que c'est important
mais on est en train de trinquer
Sébastien tu trinques avec nous allez et
allez l'OM tu me dis depuis qu'il y a
Niang à l'OM c'est rempli de chinois au
stade
c'est pas un chinoise et les Chinois
oui alors je tiens à vous dire que je
vous invite tous à mon spectacle qui
commencera le 9 novembre jusqu'au 21
novembre au quai du rire à Marseille mon
premier one man show qui s'appelle Léo
la caméra donc vous serez mes invités
puisque vous avez eu la gentillesse nous
inviter ce soir avec Kamel pour regarder
le match
c'est 80 euros vous pouvez régler tout
de suite
pour que vous voulez pas vous mettre sur
le canapé ça me dérange de voir une
femme enceinte sur une chaise pourrie
tu sais tu t'es pas beaucoup trompé
parce que on regarde la maison
vous avez le droit de le taper c'est
quoi comme comme race ce chien
c'est quoi c'est un turbo diesel
le petit qui pèse depuis tout à l'heure
c'est le chien
bêtement comme ça pendant toute la
soirée
et vous vivez toute la nuit
[Musique]
vous recevez les gens chez vous c'est
minimum quoi déjà vous
ne ressemble on dirait au bout d'un
moment on a chaud il veut prendre une
douche c'est gentil
mais doucement la serviette
je vous laisse la serviette
[Applaudissements]
une nuit
[Musique]
bon il y a pas d'eau chaude
ça fait du bien
[Musique]
merci
c'est un beau bordel dans 5 minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si c'est comme ça nous on s'en va on a
été bien gentil de accepter de venir
chez vous
[Musique]
vous avez mis quoi dans les dans les
pâtes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a marqué
n'oublie pas que le petit faut l'appeler
Pascal
[Applaudissements]
d'accord je fais un bisou aussi au
revoir et on a gagné on a gagné
merci infiniment au plaisir au plaisir
allez au revoir merci bien bien allez
viens allez et voilà rien Kamel allez
sois gentil
allez au revoir merci
c'est coincé la main dans votre boîte
aux lettres dedans ouais
impossible de retirer les dents
vous avez une trop petite
à boire là parce que je me sens tout
fait qu'est-ce qui se saigne
c'est du sang
[Musique]
c'est tentant belle forme comme ça
vous avez pas du scotch du fil
comme j'ai des fils qu'est-ce que vous
voulez faire avec des films
[Musique]
juste un petit contrôle de routine
radioactivité
parce qu'il y a une péniche qui a lâché
une caisse là
vous faites toute la rue comme ça
une odeur
dans le coin loin non pas loin justement
il y a une odeur
de toute façon moi je dois partir alors
maintenant vous allez comme je sais pas
si on va pas mettre le périmètre en
quarantaine
[Musique]
pas pouvoir vous laisser sortir
ou quoi
6 6
votre machine c'est la viande
un suppo et Oli tu parles au dessus de
la [__]
chez moi
[Applaudissements]
on prend des mesures des mesures de quoi
attendez
laisse-moi cette mesure
[Musique]
que ça dépasse partout
qui est de votre côté quoi puisque c'est
à Lui bon
pas du tout l'arbitre
voisin le voisin il dit que ça
l'appartient
pas l'arbre c'est tout ce que vous lui
piquez toutes les prunes
qui dit
vous ne touchez pas vous gardez les
moyens du tout vous coupez rien du tout
vous ne coupez rien du tout cet arbre
est à nous deux merde alors
à qui nous deux
je comprends pas ce que votre démarche
vous m'emmerdez je serais toi je suis en
train de manger je vous dis de ne pas ne
pas intervenir vous êtes chez moi alors
je sais pas moi parce que qu'est-ce que
c'est que ce machin c'est quoi
l'embrouille avec votre voisin
vous avez le droit de rentrer chez moi
bien sûr non allez voir le gars allez le
voir vous moi je sais pas mon voisin
vous êtes chez moi si je vais
chez vous j'ai pas de jardin moi j'ai
pas dit mais moi je vous dis vous
n'intervenez pas chez moi et qu'est-ce
que c'est que cette histoire mais je
sais ça débarque comme ça là ça débarque
je sais pas c'est quoi le problème avec
votre voisin moi je sais pas moi
m'emmerder je n'ai pas de problème avec
mon voisin aller voir le voisin
faute à moi si vous êtes en bises avec
le voisin je ne comprends pas votre
démarche
merde alors
comment on fait pour la facture parce
que la facture est à votre frère
vous voulez vous vous baladez avec ça là
vous voulez vous faire chier comme on
l'entend pardon je vais prendre une
trique à la fin alors une mais qu'est-ce
que vous me racontez de facture là
maintenant bon allez allez virer là
je vends du lilas vous venez de cueillir
le lilas
et puis vous voulez me rendre
parce qu'il dépasse comment il dépend il
dépasse là
vous venez cueillir du lilas chez moi
avec une échelle pendant que je ne suis
pas là et maintenant vous voulez me le
vendre non mais alors vraiment
c'est pas cher 10 balles regardez un
beau bouquet comme ça mais il y a pas
que à vous il y a celui-là
est parfait d'accord je peux en prendre
du blanc quand même
allez allez un bisou non allez goûter le
camp
[Musique]